I've never forgotten I think I was about
six years of age remember what the huge
tray of eggy bread to the table and it
was like wow man we've died and gone to
heaven
start off with a slightly stale bread
before five day old loaf leftover if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbed too
much of the eggs so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and crisp
if you're not really used with bread
crumbs eggy bread is a must in France
they call it pan perdu The Lost loaf now
thank you bread is great on his own but
serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here keeping the
skins on a lot of flavor in the skin and
also it stops the Apple from breaking
down too quickly they give these nice
chunks as opposed to sort of apple puree
now get your pan nice and hot then
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar take the sugar down to a light
caramel it's quite incredible how cheap
it is to make this and yet it was so
fitting if you haven't got apples this
recipe will work pretty much with any
fruit you've got in don't be scared to
mix a pear and an apple a banana on a
pineapple just chew it lightly tossing
the caramel get a little knob of butter
that makes a nice toffee apple flavor
really simple now you can see what's
happening the apples are caramelizing
but the staining tank is the skins on
the Apple and the caramels turned into
this nice rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples couple
of tablespoons of water in there bring
that ball and let that cook out now the
eggs
three whole eggs whisk up the eggs add
about four tablespoons of milk you want
the egg thick and rich and then lightly
sprinkle in cover tablespoons of sugar
that sweetens up the mixture and when
you start flying the bread it
caramelizes it usually a teaspoon off is
powdered cinnamon that gives the bread
that really nice spicy deliciousness
apples are glazing goofily and put them
on a low heat and get a pan on now for
the bread a teaspoon of oil and stops
the butter from burning butter in that
starts frothing get your breasts in it's
got a pretty quick name
now you don't leave the bread soaking
drain and in the pan
[Music]
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over 90 seconds each side that butter
gives that nice golden-brown color of
the egg
beautiful absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it couple of
eggs special milk leftover apples and
all of a sudden you got this stunning
breakfast
now my apples they've all delays
beautifully get a nice spoon of that
amazing juice and drizzle that over mmm
Wow if my mum saw me doing this should
kill me get a little posh again
Nana mum I'm using a touch of ice sugar
to make it look stunning not for me
takes me back to when I was 6 years of
age and I thought I just won the lottery
that is incredible the Hebert you won't
get more breakfast for your buck my
mum's incredibly delicious cinnamon eggy
bread with quick stewed apples
[Music]